サッブ パア パッス アカラナン クサラッサー ウパ サンパダー サチット パリオダパナン エータン ブッダナ サーサナン
はい では今日の話を始まります
あの メインタイトルはどうでもいいんだけど
この副題であるね 仏教の時間論ということが本当のテーマにはなります
で まあ時間論というのは
私たち人間にとってはね
なんとなく関係ありそうでなさそうで
大変気になることなんですけどね
このまあ英語でタイムと言いますけどね
これは物理学の場合はものすごい大事な一つのファクターなんですね
いろんな物理学的な計算をするとき
私は科学は知りませんだけど
これなかなか結構あのティーというね
シンボルでね これはもうよく使っているんですね
もしかすると相対性理論にも入ってるんでしたっけね
だからあの時間っていうのはかなり大事なファクターになってます
で まあ宗教になってくると
このヒンドゥ教ではね
カーラとかヤマとかね
そういう名前のこの神がいてね
その神があの時間ということでね
ヒンドゥ教によると この神
時間っていうのはある神なんですね
神様ですね だからこの人
この神っていう力があって
そこで時間っていうのを成り立つのですね
だからこのこういう人格化すると
なんとなく皆様はなんか信仰迷信っぽく考えるんだけど
これどちらでもいいやということで
そういうものを昔の人々作るんですね
だからヒンドゥ教でね
我々みんな神一体だから
森羅万象は何でもかんでもね
だからあの だから私は神であるというね
立場で見ると 自分の中にカーラという神もいるんですね
だからタイムというね
ですから まあその神はちゃんと着々と働いているんですね
えっと 信仰的に見れば
もうまた外にカーラ神がいてね
あの タイムは我々の言語でカーラなんです
普通も サンスクリット語でパーリ語で自分が使っているスリランカの言葉でも
カーラっていうのはタイムなんですね
まあそれは人格化してね
だから信仰する対象として時間の神様っていう風に頭難しいことを考えたくない一般の方々に
そういうふうに考えることもできるし
哲学的に宗教をいろいろやっている人々にとっては森羅万象
すべて神だから まあそういう全体的に普遍的に
どこでもタイムとカーラというね
働きもあるんだよとというふうに理解することもできます
はい で それで また面白いことに
また他の人間の信仰が入り込んで
カーラ神っていうのは地獄の管理者でもありますね
支配人でもありますね
ヤマっていう神は カーラはタイムで
ヤマっていうのはこの昼夜というこのシーソーですね
だから日夜はヤマなんですね
ちょっと大きく長いというかね
ピーリオド いろんなセクション
例えば朝 昼 午後 夜とかね
そうやってこのセクションごとにもカットすることはできます
瞬間瞬間でちょっと短く見れば
カーラでタイムでありまして
あのピリオドでカットするならばヤマなんですね
まあどちらでも基本的には時間ということになるんですね
そこでこの地獄の支配人がこのヤーマ神なんで
ヤーマとも言うし カーラ神とも言いますね
チベット仏教ではちゃんとカーラという言葉で使ってますからね
で なんでこの人は地獄の支配人になったんですかね
これは別に考えてみると面白いんですよ
だからこの体の中でカーラという神の働きがあって
どんどんどんどんどんどんそこを神が働いて働いてどうなるかというと
衰えて終わっちゃうでしょ
死ぬでしょうに だからカーラ神の管轄になったってことなんです
カーラ神が勝っちゃったんですね
頑張って頑張って はい
次どうするのかというと
そのずっとその神の管轄でしょ
あ この生命は次どうしようかと
肉体を持っていたんだけど
その中で私が一生懸命大変頑張ったところで
ちゃんと私のところに綺麗に戻りましたと
ではどうしようかと だから死後どうしようかというところを管理するのは
このヤマ あるいはヤーマという神であると
面白い考えですよ だから一般人にそんな難しいですよ
わかりません だからあんた死んじゃったらね
地獄に落ちて そこでヤーマ神がいて審判をするんだと言えば
えらいわかりやすくなっちゃうんですね
で そういうことでも地獄の支配人ということにもなるんですね
だから あの ちょっと複雑な哲学思考と神話的な迷信というか
信仰も一緒にセットで出してるんですね
あのマクドナルドのハンバーグと同じで
あのあの上と下にあるパンはそれほど体にも悪いとは思いません
だけど真ん中に挟んでいるあれ
何でしたっけ？あれ食っちゃったら心臓発作起こして死ぬんですね
しかしそれ食いたくて外のパンで挟んでるんだからね
よくわからないですね
これは そういうわけで
このヒンドゥー教の物語も
なんとなくそうやって
この一般 何も学問 何も知識のない人々の信仰
そこと哲学的な思考 一つに合わせてハンバーガーにしてして売ってるんです
そういうことで ヒンドゥー教を学ぶ方々は
そこをよく理解しないと正しく学ぶことはできなくなる
今日は私はヒンドゥー教の先生ではありませんだけど
忘れました わざわざ早く仏教の方だと
で あの まあ一応そういうことで
地獄の支配人であると
それで私たちはこの哲学的なところを捨てちゃって
信仰的なところだけ大事にするんですね
本当にマクドナルドのハンバーグと同じなんですね
ものすごい油で脂肪の塊である
真ん中のところだけ狙って美味しくてという感じになっているんですね
それで仏教も神話として仏教でもこの神を例として使ってますね
仏典でもヤーモやヤママハラージャとかね
というヤマという大王という感じで
これは仏教では明らかに神話なんですね
神話にしちゃって もう人が死んじゃったら
あの山王に会いますよというエピソードあるんですね
それはもう確実にそんな神がいるというスタンスじゃなくて
人間に理解 わかりやすく
このポイントを理解するために使っているんです
そこでこの世の中で この永遠という言葉がありましてね
日本語でもありますね
永遠 永遠は日本語ですからね
これはどんな言語にもあるんですね
例えばラストティング
エバーラスティングとか
英語にしたってもね パーマネントとかね
フォーレバーとかね という言葉はいくらでもありますね
このフォーエバー あるいはラスティング
パーマネント という言葉になってくると
時間というのはどうなるんですかね
神 魂などの永遠になる実体は時間外のものとして見ているんです
だからこういう言葉を使う人々にとっては時間論がないんですね
なんかそんなややこしいことを考えていなくて
時間と関係ない何かあるんだというふうなものを考えているんですね
時間外のものとせめているんですね
皆 時間という概念を持ってるでしょう
持ってるようです それでこのみんな永遠の魂とかね
不死なる魂とかね いろんなことを言ってますが
我々一般的にね 私たち私たちは時間という概念
誰でも持っているんです
だから時間という概念を持っちゃうと
永遠というのはちょっと成り立たないんですね
ですから いわゆるないものに憧れるんです
現実的に時間に追われて生きているんです
それで自分にないのは永遠なんですね
それで永遠に憧れちゃうんですね
だから ないものねだりっていうのは
人間のなんかね 普通な気持ちになってますからね
どうしてもないものを欲しがっちゃうんですね
それですごく面白くて
時間に追われている人々が永遠というものが欲しがる
しかし 仏教では時間論はありません
世の中にはあります 仏教では時間論というものがないんです
時間とは何ぞやということは全くないんです
そういうわけで 今日のテーマはこれで終了です
でないものをしゃべれませんだからね
で じゃあこれからお帰りになりたければどうぞ
これから まあただ申し訳ないんだけど
ただ世間話にします 存在しないんです
時間は 時間は存在しないので
時間論は成り立ちません
カーラとかヤーマとかね
何だらかんだり言ったって
仏教はこんなもの 仏教は神様
神様に対しても同じことを言ってます
言ってますからね そんなやつは存在しませんと
同時に時間というものも存在しないんです
私たち人間の頭の中に時間という観念があります
これは頭の中にあるんです
それもあると言ったっても
そういう観念なんですね
そういう考えですね 概念ですね
あるんです 観念なので主観的な感情であります
だから時間というのはあなたの主観的な感情だよと
はっきり言えばそんなもんなんです
それ 怒り 嫉妬 落ち込みと同じもんなんです
で ある人が怒りで怒っていたってもね
もう一人の人も必ず怒らなくちゃあかんということはないでしょう
ある人は嫉妬で悩んでいるんだから
人類みんな嫉妬で悩んでいるべきでないでしょうに
勝手にして下さいと だから感情っていうのは各自で好き勝手でしょうに
怒りでハチャメチャ悩んでる人もいて
欲でハチャメチャ悩んでる人もいて
嫉妬でハチャメチャ悩んでる人もいて
おお これこれから嫉妬する二人見ても嫉妬の程度が違うでしょ？もういつでも機嫌が悪くて
怒りで感情で悩んでる人もいますが
怒りを持ってる 何人か調べてみたら程度が違うんですね
ある人はただ機嫌が悪いだけで
ある人がきつい言葉まで喋っていて
ある人がもう体も病気になってしまって
怒りのせいで ある人はもうもう加害者になって
もう人に迷惑までかけたりしてとかね
これいろいろありますね
だから一貫してないし
様々でしょうし 怒る自由もありますよ
怒らない自由もありますからね
これ 主観的な感情なんですね
だから時間も同じことなんですよ
したがって時間という感覚は人によって変わるものです
あの時間 どのように感じるかっていうことはね
人によって違います 年によっても違います
で 小学生ぐらいのね  1年生ぐらい
あるいは 2年生から以下の子供たちを集めてなんか喋りましょう
では何分できると思う？ 1時間できると思う
絶対できません もうまとめてもらうことは
せいぜいまあ10分もものすごい難しいんですね
で かなり来るできる人なら 10
分 15分ぐらいは子供たちを一つのテーマにまとめてもらうことはできます
それからギャーッと子供たちがもう外れてしまうんですよ
で だから大人の1時間半 2
時間ぐらい 子供には15分で終わっちゃうんです
あれは子供の時間感覚なんです
で 例えば大人に 2時間かけて話をする
心変わってほしいと 子供には5分話す 5
分以上聞いてくれないんだから
誰が変わると思う？子供はしっかり変わるんです ５
分の話で 大人は２時間しゃべったのに
あれ あんたなんか言った？っていう状態なんです
だからそれは時間の流れなんですね
だから 30年も喋ってますけどね
もう結構長い付き合いの方々もいるんだけど
もう一番長く私と付き合ってる人々に
この仏教の基礎は何ですか？聞いてみてください
知らないんです あんた五戒の意味でもわかっているの？と聞いてみてください
びっくりしますよ ある方にね
ずっと協力してきて ボランティアまで来て
何年もなんですよ 必死なんですね
それでなんかちょこっと精神的な問題がありまして
まあそれ解決するために
私はそれ至って簡単だから
ちょっと慈悲の瞑想 えっ？慈悲の瞑想ってなんですかねと
これ  7  8年  10 年間 私といろんな活動した人なんです
それね 私ももうカッとなりましたけどね
それ私が情けなくてね
もう石にはいくら水をかけても柔らかくならないんでだと
なんで私は理解しないのかと
もう自分のあほらしさに腹が立ったんです
石 石は水につけたっても
柔らかくならないんだと
で それで私がこういう余計なことを言ったっても
大事なポイントあるんですよ
あの子供の10分っていうのは
子供にとっては変化するのにすごい大事な時間なんです
だから同じことは 30 分っていうのはもう耐えられないんですね
それから別なことをしなくちゃあかんのです
だから 大人の時間感覚と子供の時間感覚が違うんです
というわけで 時間ということは
各生命によって違うものなんです
これ 主観的な気持ちですから
あれは科学的なファクターではないんです
それでこの勝手な時間感で困るんですよ
だから子供が何か要求したら
母親がそれしてあげるためには
まあこれぐらいって もうちゃんと
例えばお腹がすいた ご飯食べたいと
あんた何食べたい？って言ったら
おにぎり食べたいって言ったっても
おにぎりがない なので母親が炊飯器からご飯取っても熱いし
これ丁寧になんとかおにぎりを握らなくちゃあかんでしょうに
それでおにぎりに何入れるのかと
また聞いちゃうでしょうね
これ おにぎり食べたいって言ったか
子供はもう早く早く まだですか
まだですかとお腹がすいた
もう死にそうやとギャーギャー言うんですよ
それでお母さんがちょっと待ってください
待ちませんやとかね そういう出来事
なんで起こるんですかね
で 子供の時間感覚では
もうお腹がすいたと言った時点で
もう食べなくちゃあかんですよ
時間短いんですね 短い時間で変化してしまうんですね
大人から見れば もうこれにはやっぱり最低 5 6 分はかかりますと
あの 5 6 分は子供には待てないんです
だから母親が勘違いするんですね
落ち着きがないんだと
落ち着きがないでしょうかね
あれは時間の取り方の個人差なんですね
はい それで困っちゃうでしょう
結局は みんなそれぞれバラバラな時間を持っていると
社会生活をする人間には
皆従うべき時間という概念が一緒になっていますね
だからもうどうしようもないんですね
何かみんな認める ジェネラルルーズというね
何かもう誰でも認める
何か必要になるんですね
だから学校に来る子供たちは
子供たちの時間で学校に来ると
大人の教師たちは自分たちの時間で学校に行くというと
なんか学校という組織が成り立たないんで
学校は社会ですからね
ですから 誰でも認める何か必要になるんですね
何かルールが必要になるんです
で ルールっていうのはもう人間決めるんですよ
だから我々作るルールは宇宙法則ですかね
日本人は日本人に適切なルールを作ってるでしょ
日本憲法やらいろんなもの
だからって地球上のみんな
それを守らなくちゃいけないんですかね
関係ないんですね 他の生命には
そういうわけで 時間っていうのはもうそこで人間が作ったルールになってるんですね
いろいろ時間の考えがあったのですが
今 皆  24時間というのは 1 日で
60 分というのは 1時間 1
時間で云々と もうもう分秒までまあ作ってあります
だから秒はまたカットして
ナノ ナノ秒まで まあ考えてくる
科学の世界でナノっていう言葉が出てくるんであってね
ミリ秒 ナノ秒とかね その場合は 60 分じゃなくて
普通の10のあれで分けていくんですね 1
秒まではもう 60 分と 60 秒で 1
秒になってくると もうあの10のあれ 10
でもう分けて分けていっちゃうんですね
だから 1時間で取っちゃうと 24時間で1日にしていてね
だからそこはそんなに一貫してないんですね
分け方は 全部10だったらね 10
秒は1分でとかね で 10
分は1時間でとかね したってもいいんだけど
これまたちょっと難しくなってくるんですね
いろいろ時間の考えがあったのですが
っていうのは この 1 日 24時間っていうのは最近の考えで
昔はそう思っていなかったんです
昔 日本では 1 日何時間でしたっけ
あの江戸時代の時計 どうなってますかね
あの 24時間じゃないんです
時間の取り方は違い 稼ぎ方が違いましたからね
だから  そのその時のね
で 時代で人間いろいろ考える
インド文化では6時間なんですね
1 日は sorry シックスティアワーズ
ということは60時間ですね 24
時 24時じゃないんです
だから 1 日は60時  1時は60分 1
分は60秒 全部60 60 60
にしているんです だからインド文化の 1 秒っていうのは
今の時計の 1 秒より早いんです
あのツーアンドハーフなんですね
計算すると   インドのあの秒
2.5 秒は現代の 1 秒なんです
で そういうふうに時間の感覚っていうのはね
それぞれ違いますからね
最近はまあこんな風になっているんです
時間は科学で使う温度
カロリー グラムなどのユニットの一つです
時間というのは一つのある計算するために使うユニット単位ですね
だからそういう理論 仏教にあるわけないでしょ
グラムとはどれぐらいか
どんなものかとかね ものすごくくだらない話になっちゃうんですね
科学で使うユニットも存在しないんです
それでこのユニット存在しますかね
1 グラムっていうのは存在する？温度から 1度 2度とか存在する
存在しないんです 水が凍る時は 0度というんですね
もう 100度で沸騰します
それで 0度 100度と言うんだけど
あれ 勝手につけた名前でしょ
ただ 凍った水が冷たくて
沸騰する 水が熱くて じゃあこちらに 0 にして
こちらに 100 にしましょうと
この間はもう 100等に分けてみましょうというふうな考えなんですね
だから明らかに頭の中の観念なんです
温度というものはね 存在しない
そういうわけで 今我々が使っているセルシウスという温度を測る
あれが水の変化を見てね
氷と沸騰する状態間で決めちゃって
わからないかな ファレンハイトというあれもありますけど
ファレンハイトの場合は 32 degrees というのは氷
これで 180 degrees というのは
この沸騰することで あれ
どんなことでどう作ったかよくわからないんですね
このフランスで作った
このもうセルシウスはもうわかりやすいんですけどね
というわけで 何かを参照しないとユニットを測れません
時間を計算するために何を参照しているんですかね
これが問題なんです いや
温度は水で 時間って何を参照していますかね
私 そこら辺は全然調べて研究してないんだから
私には私は答えを持ってません
皆様は一応私より知識人なので
いろいろ知っているだろうと思います
で 昔の人間がこの太陽ですね
で 太陽でね 昼と夜がでっかいものがありまして
これはあの えーとえーと
カーラと山ですね カーラと山という神に名前が 2つありますからね
で 山であって 山はまず昼夜でね
それから昼もいろいろセクションがあるんだから
そちらにカーラというタイムというものを入れちゃって
とにかくまあそうなっちゃったんですね
それで昼と夜 2つなんですけど
一つもまとめて一にしちゃったんですね
ワンデー 1 日 だからワンデー 1 日というためには
もう昼というものも夜という 2つがセットにしないといけない
そこを分けて分けて分けて
時間なんかを作っちゃったんですね
一般人にはそれで十分です
しかし これ結構曖昧なんでね
精密な計算になってくると
時々昼が長くちゃって夜が短い時もある
北極とかはね 無茶違うでしょうに
昼は何ヶ月間もする 夜になったらまた何ヶ月間もとかね
もうこれあまりにもいい加減バラバラでおっかないんですね
やっぱり頭が論理的に明確な計算したいんですね
脳みそが しかし これあんまりうまくいかないんですね
それで無理をするんです
昼だからデイタイム 昼の時間なのに
無理やりに夜にするんですね
例えば夏はもう 8時も明るい
8時って まあ大体明るい程度とかね
7時は明るいでしょうね
もう 7時だから店しまいますとかね
それは開けておきて  9時までと言いたいんだけど
9時まで開けておいて
また朝 5時ぐらいでまた開けてくださいと
もう明るくて太陽が出ているんだから
だから夏なんか買い物をしようと思ったら
もう汗びっしょりで朝買い物するためにもう 9時半まで待たなくちゃいかんですね
もう私の体にはもう昼も過ぎてるぐらいなんで
そこで我々はちょっと無理をしているんですね
で なぜかというと この 1回転にとにかく無理やりにでも合わせようと
だからヤマの考えがもうずれちゃうんですね
それでもっと精密に考えてみると
地球の自転もあんまり一定しないんですね
なんか人間と同じく まあいろいろ我々にわからないぐらい微妙かもしれませんだけど
この回転速度も自転速度も
回転速度もそう一定していないんです
微妙に変わるんです だからまあ
例えば 1年といったら
1回転すれば 1年でしょ
でも我々はもう計算の方が頭の中の計算の方が大事ですから
もう1回転完了していないんだけど
1年やというんですね
そこで 4年ぐらい経ったら結構幅が残っちゃって
それでもう 1日足しましょうと
4年ごとに 366日が 1年にするという
えらい無理やりな計算なんですね
なんでこんな無理いい加減なことできるのかというと
時間というのは頭の中の観念だからなんです
これから最近ね 機械 精密な機械作っちゃって
機械はちゃんと正しく秒を数えてくれるんですね
あの なんとか時計ありますね
あの電子時計 なんだらかんだらっていうね
で これは結構大きくて
誰も手にはめることはできませんだからね
まあいろいろ大学 研究所やらね
政府のところとか  1箇所 2箇所であるだけでね
どこにもあるわけじゃないんです
その時計が精密に あの
あの なんて言いますか
この放射とかね その原子の波長で秒をチェックしているんですね
だから原子が丁寧に波長を出してますから
そこで数えて 1 秒計算するんですね
で  1 秒長いんですよ 電子が
セルシウスの電子がもうすごく早くスピーディーに波長を出してます
だから結構数えられますよ
簡単にこれぐらいの波長が出たら 1 秒ということにして
だからその時計ではいたって簡単に
1 秒の 100分の1っていうのはいたって簡単に計算できるんです
はい それが地球の事件と関係なく
宇宙の存在とも関係なく
自分の原子の中の素粒子の働きだけを見て波長を出してますから
この時間は誰の時間にも合えなくなっちゃうんですね
今現在 我々使っている時間っていうのは
誰の時間にも合わないんです
だからあの何年か経つと秒も変えなくちゃいけないんですよ
その時大騒ぎするんですね
あの 最近は起きてないな
何年前で あの  1 秒増やしたんですね
一回だけ  60 61になったら 1 分になるという
であれは電子時計があまりも精密だから
人間使っている時間が遅くて一定しないんだから
そこを時間合わせてそこまで合わせて何になるかよくわかりませんだけどね
はい 次は犬が主人を飼うはめになります
時間は人間の便利を考えて作ったんですね
頭の中の概念に過ぎないのに
この観念は私たちを支配管理しているんです
だから自分に便利だと思って
同じ時間で子供たちも先生も学校で集まって欲しかったんです
だからもうどういう時間という決まりが作ったんだけど
決まりを それからそれが我々を突然支配することになってくるんです
グラムカロリーメーター云々のユニットも
結局私たちを支配しているんです
存在しないユニット思考を作るんですよ
例えば音を計算できるでしょ？デシベル
なんだらかんだらとか
光も計算するんですね
なんとかのユニットで
なんでももうみかんの甘さがどれぐらい？糖度が 20 なんやどうやってあれ
どんな仕組みかわからないんですね
あるいは酸っぱさもまた計算するんですね
何であろうともユニット作っちゃうんですね
水の場合でもね  PH 値というものがありまして
なんだこれよと よくわかりませんだけどね
とにかく PH 値でそこをいろいろ書いたりはするんですね
こちらも書いていると
今 PH なんだらかんだら書いて書いてないんですかね
うーん まあ硬度だけ書いてますけどね
それはあまり数字にならんですね
数字は書いてない で こんなものを作ったら便利だと思って作っちゃったんだけど
次それで管理されます
例えばあるデパートでみかん売ってる場合は
みかんには糖度はこれぐらいなければいけませんと決めるでしょ
でなきゃ有名なデパートの食品売り場だからね
厳しいんですね それでみかん作る人々が困るでしょう
自然なみかんだから もう糖度はそんなようわからないんですね
それであれやこれやと工夫して工夫して工夫して
ある一定の糖度の人工的なみかん作って
自然そのもので作っ 太陽が育んだなんだらかんだら言って売ってるんですね
嘘ばっかりなんですけどね
太陽の恵みをあなたの手元に届きますとかね
いろんなことを言ったりして
あれはすごい人工的に糖度管理しているんですね
かぼちゃにしたっても同じことで
これでいろんなユニットで測ることにしたところで
逆に自分がやられているという
これあまりわからないんだったら
この例えでわかるでしょ
体の健康状態より 我々はの測りの数字が気になるでしょ
測りの数字がちょっと上がっちゃうと
ああ ダメだ これはまずい
これはもう大変 別にあなた調子が悪くなったのかと聞きたいんだけどね
時々体調が最悪なんですけど
測りの数字が下がっちゃって
ああ 万々歳 よかったよかったとかね
体重が減ったとかね 体重が減るか増えるかどうでもいいでしょ
健康で生きていなくちゃあかんでしょうに
体重と健康には何かすごく緩めた関係がありますよ
あの不可分離の関係じゃないんです
緩い関係があるはあるんだけど
そこで体重はグラム単位で量るでしょう
それで標準体重をいろんなものを作ったりして
これからも測りはあなたに命令する羽目になります
体重計が 食うなよと それが私は犬が主人を飼うという世界やと
だから我々人間が 犬が主人を飼う世界に生きているんですね
あべこべの世界で生きているんです
それでただでさえ苦なのにと
生きることは本来苦です
仏教から見れば逃げられません
その苦しみから その苦が足らなくて
もっと苦しみたいと 人間がね
時間などの様々な概念観念を作って
それらの罠に喜んで飛び込みます
もっともっと苦しみたいと
だから自分で罠を作って
厳しい罠をいろいろ作って飛び込むんです
だから時間に束縛されるわ
もうグラムに束縛されるわ
ペーハに束縛されるわ
もういろんなことに束縛されるんですよ
あれでこれで 例えばうるさく感じなくても
ノイズを計算するものを持ってきて
ああ もうデシベルがこれぐらいだと人間の健康にダメやと
あなた実際うるさいと感じるのかと聞いたら別にいいと
しかし この数字を見てくださいと
今最近 PPM なんだらかんだらという話があるでしょ
だからもう聞いただけでうーんとなっちゃうんですね
PPM 20  2 なんで 0.25
ああ これ危険だ 危険だ
死ぬかもしれませんとかね
だからもう PPM 2.5 じゃなくても
もうもうもう 1 ミリのホコリでも入っちゃう
マスクをかけて偉そうなことで頑張ってますよ
あんなものは 1 ミリのものでも入りますけど
これ 0.25 入らないものだったら
空気もだいたい入らないんですよ
だからしっかりともう
粘土とかね なんだかでワックスで閉めた方がいいと思いますよ
そうすると入りません
で じゃあ呼吸困難があるのか
鼻がもう出ているのかどうかね
喉がなんとかとか そうやって
あ やっぱり空気が悪いと決めてもいいのに
そうじゃないんです 数字で決めるんです
だから数字が頭に入ると
本当に心配でどうしようもないんですね
ちょこちょこと空気が透明でない
このもうもう四国あたり
あちらこちら行く場合はね
それほど透明でなくなった
みんなこれは黄砂とか
あれやこれやとかね そう言われると
私もちょっとなんとなく
ああそうですか だってテレビで聞いているんだからね
もうなんとかもう 2.5 も入ってるかもしれませんとかね
言うんだから困ったなとかね
本当は困ってないんだけど
困ったなっていう気分になっちゃうんです
だから私たちは便利を図って作った
観念が我々をコントロールする
これは脳科学者が脳科学的にはいつでも脳はそうなるんだと
脳はいろんな概念を作って
それから脳そのものの働きをコントロールするんだと
働かなくなるようにするんだと
例えば 脳がデータ処理するためにデータ処理がうまくいかない場合は
自分という存在しない観念を作っちゃうんですね
例えば手が痛くなりました
足の方が痒くなりました
だから痛みと痒みっていうのはどうやってまとめるんですかね
まとめられなくなっちゃう
それで脳がもう面倒くさいんだから
じゃあ私ってものを入れて
私の足が痒くなって 手が痛くなりました
私の はい わかりました
まとめましたと あんないい加減なからくりで結局どうなるのかというと
私という観念が脳の働きを全部押さえておくんです
脳に自由に働かないようにするんです
勝手に作ったのはいいんだけど
存在しないものを それから自分を管理されてしまいます
だから時間もそういうものになっているんです
それから観念に支配されて
管理されて生かされる脳で新たな苦が起きます
だからただでさえ苦なのに
これもうおっかない もうもう潰されるぐらい我々は苦しみをたくさん作っているんです
これは自業自得です あの自業自得っていうのは
しっかりした哲学用語ですよ
冗談遊びじゃないんです
自分で作って自分で得るという意味でしょ
だから大体これは一般的にニュアンスとしてはネガティブなんですね
自業自得は 哲学的に思考的にはネガティブ
ポジティブ どちらにも使う
普通なんですけど 一般的にはこれネガティブで使ってますよ
だから科学者も一般人も作っている様々なユニット思考
単義思考 すべて自業自得で苦しむんです
だってケツは進む測るでしょ
血圧を測る場合はどうやって測るのかと
よくわからなくなっちゃって
空気の圧が圧力がありますからね
同じ数字で測るんですね
本当は空気の圧力と体の働きが違うんだけどね
それでいろんな機械作っちゃって
血圧を測る それで標準というものを作っちゃうんですね
あの標準っていうのはなかなか作れるものじゃないんです
標準血圧っていうのは各人間に違うんです
すべての人間に決まってる標準血圧はないんです
それですべての人間に決まってる標準血圧を作ってからは
ただ測ったっても もう自分がビシビシ健康なんですけど
何の不調もないんだけど
もう心臓もしっかり働いてますけど
あら 血圧が高い あ どうしようかとと思っちゃうんです
それで この存在しない化け物の標準血圧に自分の体の血圧を合わせようとして
いろんな工夫をして 薬を飲んだりして
健康な体を壊しちゃうんです
やれやれと それで測ってみたら
見事に 120 と何だらかんだらになっていると
これなんだこの人生はと
いつだって我々はそれで科学的だ
現代的だ 最新医学やとかいろんなことを威張ってるだけ
あれは鏡よ鏡よ この世で一番美しいのはまた誰ですか？というような感じでね
自分しかいないんだから
お前だけでしょうやと
どんな鏡にも聞いてみてということですね
世界一美しいのは自分ですよ
だって鏡に他の人を映せないでしょ
だから ああいう物語にしたっても
人間の心理状態を語ってますよ
自分たちがそうやっていろんなものを作っちゃって
それからこの化け物に合わせようとして
結構苦しんで生きているんです
だから時間は存在しない
グラムは存在しない カロリーは存在しない
ジュールは存在しない
何も で 仏教何かに参考するんですよ
その場合は  1 カロリーとは
あの 1 グラムの水をね
1 度上げるために必要な熱量でしょ
どこで 1度はどうやって計算するのかというと
氷と沸騰 あれで計算するんですね
だから総合的にあまり当てにならんんだけどね
本当は 仏教ではもうただ単に単純でね
一切現象は無常ですと
それしか語られてないんです
それが真理です 変化し続けるんです
物事は 止まることはありません
推測的に言えば 初めも見つからず
終わりも見えずなんです
そうすると時間ってなんか見事に似てるでしょ？時間には始まりもなく終わりもないんですね
で この無常をいろんな角度で見て
カロリーというわ デシベルというわね
圧力はどんな数字で数えるんでしたっけ？え？パスカル
パスカル それで圧力を作るわ
稼げるわ 時期の変化は時計で計算するわ
あらゆるユニットが世の中で存在するんです
科学を勉強すると もうユニットはもうものすごい大量になるんですね
このユニットはなんで成り立つのかというと
本当はすべて無常というところに
無常はどのように どんな無常はどのように見たのかと
それでいい例えがありましてね
あの 目が見えない人々がね
もう王様の 庭で集まってね
皇帝で集めて で 生まれつき目が見えないんだからね
その人々にこのでっかい象さんを見せるんです
で 見せても目が見えないんだから
みんなにではこの象さんはどんなものかと王に報告しなさいと
言うと 目が見えない人はそれぞれの部品を触って
尾っぽを触った人はわかりました
王様 象さんっていうのは
この箒と似ていますよとかね
いろいろ言うんです 象牙を触った人は何言うんですかね
野球バットに似てるんでしたか？とかね
それよりちょっと硬いとか
では 象さんは箒に似ていますかね
象さんのお腹触ると これでっかい山みたいなとかね
わかりました 王様 象さんっていうのは山の形取ってますよと
で いろいろ言ってます
だからそのことを現代我々も科学者もやっているんです
現象は無常ですけど ある角度で見て
カロリー計算する 温度を計算する
パスカルで計算する デシベルで計算するとかね
いろんなことをやっています
じゃあ無常というもので考えると
どんなものでもそのままでいないんですね
すっと変わっちゃう また変わった
また変わっちゃう また変わっちゃう
また変わっちゃう 変わるは変わるは変わるは変わる
そうなってくると この現象は次変わる
この現象も次に変わる
この現象は次に変わると言ったら推測するとどこまででもとなっちゃうでしょ
ではそうすると過去に行ってみると
行ってみましょう この現象はあったのは別な現象変わって
それがあったのは別な現象変わって
それがあったのは別な現象が変わって
どこまで行くんで遡るんですかね
だから見つからないんですね
全然 で 無常からそういう風に初め
見つからず 終わりも見えず
ということが出てくる
これ輪廻っていうのはそれなんですね
それ仏教では輪廻と言うんですね
サンサーラ サンサーラっていうのはもう輪廻
この回転ぐるぐるじゃないんです
だから輪廻といって日本語の単語何でしたっけ？回転するって意味でしたっけ
うーん そうですね で サンサーラっていうのはフロー
流れなんです ストリーム
フローという意味なんですね
フローと言ったらフロー
皆様はどうやって発音しますか？わかりません
あのフローですかね まあフローといえば
フローといえばいろいろありますからね
書き方によって意味が変わりますからね FF
FLWのフローもありますけどね
FLOWフローもありますからね
もう書き方によって意味が変わりますけど FLOW
のフローなんですね だからストリーム
まあストリームという英語の単語は日本語にもなってますから
ストリーム ストリームなんとかとかね
もう流れるんですね だから現象が流れる
流れる 流れる そこで初めも見えず
見つからず 見つからず
初めの場合は終わりは見えず
物質の輪廻もあり あ 輪廻がありますね
精神の輪廻もあります
そこで皆様も科学者も物質だけでしょ
考えているのは 僕はそうじゃなくて
物質にも輪廻があって
フローがあって ストリームなんです
精神もストリームで流れると
様々な時間 一つの現象は直ちに次の現象に変化します
この変化に対して変化無常だと言わず
誤って時間と言うんです
この時間という言葉を誤って使っているんです
これ 仏教の時間論から言れば
まあ仏教的にも時間論は成り立ちますけど
それはこの科学者が使っている時間関係観念なんですね
この時間ということは
世界の常識なんですね
何か変化する 変化することを認めません
時間で言うんですね ご飯作って 1時間も経ちましたと
これは 1時間前作ったご飯ですよと
何を否定していますかね
ご飯が変化していくこと
もう変わったこと 今あなた作ったご飯ではないと
別な品物やと認めたくない
だから 1時間前作りましたと時間で言うんです
ものは同じですと 随分誤ったいい加減な使い方なんです
はっきり言えば  1時間前私が作ったご飯作りましたが
これではありませんと
私が作ったご飯は柔らかくて温かくて
食べると美味しいものでしたと
食べたならば これがちょっと冷えて硬くて
あんまり美味しくないんだと
だから私が作ったのはこれではありませんとはっきり言えますけどね
だって変化しているんだから
間違ってますよ で 女性がね
４０歳の男女を見て これ私が産んだ子供やと
本当？でもどう見えてあなたより倍でっかい体ですけど
どうやって産んだかわかりませんだけど
だから４０年前産んだのはまるっきり別なものなんです
別な品物なんですね 産んだのは
今別ですからね もうどうでもいいんで
関係ないんです そこであの時間
感覚で囚われちゃって結構苦労しますよ
あれで結構苦労します
そこで時間っていうのは様々というわけで
人間になってくると あの
４０年前産みました そういうことで時間によるんですね
だから賞味期限 使用期限
いろいろあるでしょう
で 桜が散る時間と豆腐が腐ってしまう時間は違います
この文章を書きながら
私は豆腐が腐ってしまうっていうのはちょっとダブっちゃってね
もうとっくに腐ってるんだからね
だから豆腐がさらに腐る
腐ってしまうと書かなくちゃあかんですね
精密に書けば で 私が言いたいとこは
皆様にはこれ今までの話難しいでしょうね
で これがちょっと簡単でよろしい
桜が見て あ 桜が散るのは早いなと思っちゃうでしょ
豆腐の場合は まあ 2 日間ぐらいは冷蔵庫に入れればね
大丈夫やと  2 日間じゃないんで
1ヶ月間でも冷蔵庫でも大丈夫ですけどね
そういうわけで この私の場合はね
買った豆腐が思い出して
じゃあ今日食べますと
そこまでは賞味期限なんです
印刷してる日時じゃないんです
今日はめんどくさいと思ったらまた大丈夫です
何か食べたいなと冷蔵庫見ると豆腐見つかったら
ああ 豆腐があるんじゃないかと
今日食べなかったらもう賞味期限切れますからといって食べるんです
そんな感じで だからまだ死んでないんだから
それで大丈夫でしょ だから私は間違ったらもうもう間違ってません
ブッダからまだまだそういうことで死んでないんだから大丈夫ということですね
だからその場合でも 時間感覚を私スマナサーラという人間と皆様って違うでしょ
だから 4月26と書いたら
皆様が必死でもう今日か明日以内で食べようとするでしょ
賞味期限切れる 1日か 2 日前で
とにかく食べなかったらすぐ直行死ぬと思っているんですね
気をつけた方がいいんで
まあ行く先が危ないんだからね
だからできるだけ命を守って長生きした方がいいんです
で だからそこはあの その方々の時間感覚なんですよ
だから今日は何日でしたっけ？まあ 20 日ですね
だからこの 4月20日とあったら
豆腐の上にね あ 大変だ
これは今日食べなくちゃとかね
って驚いちゃって 心配しちゃってね
その方の時間感覚 で 私がまあまあ
こんな書いたってもね
まだ大丈夫やと どうせ店はね
もういくらか日にちの
あの 何て言いますか 隙間が置いて書きますからね
でなきゃ大変危険なことになりますが
大丈夫やと思ったりするし
だから同じ品物についても
それぞれ人が自分の時間を持ってるんです
で さらにこの まあ取り立てが欲しいやと思ってる人もいるでしょ
取り立て牛乳とかね 取り立て野菜とかね
で それも一つの時間感覚で
取り立てだけが美味しいって言ったらね
じゃあ納豆の取り立てどうですかね？まずいでしょう
あれ 腐ってもらわないとカビがいっぱい生えて
だからまあ 1年発酵した方がよろしいとかね
5年発酵した方がよろしいとかね
という品物もありますね
古ければ古いほど美味しいものもあるでしょ
それから果物 野菜などは
新しいものが新しいほどよろしいというものもありますね
そういうことで 枝から熟したリンゴを取って食べることができれば
とてももう取ったばっかりだから美味しいとかね
しかし リンゴはもう 2 3ヶ月間は持ちますし
そうするとなんかちょっと味がということになる
しかし リンゴでジャム作ったら
作ったばっかしのジャムっていうのはまずいんですよ
あれ 砂糖いっぱい入れてね
もうもう何て言いますか
ジンジャー生姜ちょっと入れたり
いろんなものを入れたりしてね
もうコトコトコトコトあれ溶かしちゃって
作りたてのジャムはどうですかね
まずいんです あんなのは食べられません
まあ食べられますけど
あまり美味しくないんですね
パンに味見はできますけど
パンに乗って食べようってその気にはならないんです
それが冷やして時間置いたからなんですね
味なのは それで味噌みたいなものは結構時間経った方がいいものはありますね
そういうわけで 品物によって時間感覚が変わるんです
科学者の計算とは違うんですね
山は山でなくなって別な現象に変化する時間と
せっかく作ったマイホームが住めなくなる時間と違います
時間のユニットをですから作るのは難しい
これで私が何か言ってないものを口で喋ろうと思って入れてないんです
この時間ユニットって何なのかと
これが あの ライフライフ
LIFE 命寿命で考えてください
山一個の寿命が時間のワンユニットなんです
で 家を作るでしょ その家が作ってからもう住めなくなる時間は
この家の寿命ですね この寿命が 1個単位なんです
だから私がここ この世で
れたら 1個だけ時間もらうんですね
ワン一つの単位 これにはなかなかラベルがないんだから
もうライフでいいんでしょ？ ワンライフ
山もワンライフもらいます
豆腐も豆乳から豆腐になった時点で
豆腐としてワンライフ
豆乳としてワンライフ
大豆としてワンライフなんです
大豆やら米やら味噌に変わったら
味噌としてワンライフもらいます
このワンライフはものすごい様々ななんです
一貫しない 一定にならないんです
これがすごい大事なことなんです
これが本当に皆様が理解するべき
ことなんです ダブっちゃうと困るんです
だから桜の花がワンライフもらいます
このワンライフを完了して死ぬんです
悲しいことではありません
ワンちゃんがワンライフもらいます
そこで生まれた時は赤ちゃんで可愛くて
また8歳で遊んだりして
それからもう若者になって中年になって
おじさんにおばさんになって死ぬんです
目も見えなくなったりして
耳も聞こえなくなったりして
死ぬんです ワンライフ完璧に生きてるんです
これで私のワンライフで見たら悲しいな
ワンちゃんが死んじゃったなとかね
13年も私と一緒に生活しましたよとかね
それでくだらない感情
悲しみが生まれてくるんです
なぜならば 自分のワンライフとワンちゃんのワンライフを一緒にして考えちゃったんです
それがアホ以外誰もやってはいけません
皆さんがそういうことをやっているならば
どうぞ自由に だから帽子がはめるながらしょうがないでしょう
で ゴキブリで生まれたらワンライフもらいますよ
これは人間のワンライフから見ると 1ヶ月間かもしれませんだけど
ゴキブリはちゃんと卵から出てきて
子供の時期があって もう青年の時期があって
年取ってまた子供作って死ぬんです
それワンライフなんです
富士山も現れてきて それからじわじわと変化して
やがて消えます 日本の国ももうじわじわと現れちゃって
火山活動で今も火山活動で
それでじわじわじわじわ変化して
やがて消えます それで日本という土地のワンライフ
そこで地球というこの玉にもある時期が現れちゃって
ワンライフいただいて
このワンライフ終わったら消えます
これが太陽というものも
いろんなガスが固まっちゃって
そこで太陽になっちゃって
ワンライフをもらいます
って このワンライフ終わったら消えてしまいます
このワンライフの中に生老病死が成り立つんです
それで私たちがどこで間違うかというと
自分の ワンライフから桜を見る
ああ 早く散るんだな なんで悲しい
アホなこと言うと なんて悲しいことかなとかね
ですから 日本人の無常観っていうのはそんな程度でしょ
桜の花散るのを見て まあもうやっぱり無常だなとかね
あれはもうバカな無常論で
無常論であって 仏教の無常論じゃないんです
で その場合 間違いは自分が永遠やというスタンスで言うんだからなんです
自分が永遠という 例えば私がすごく長生きするんだというスタンスで見ると
ワンちゃんが死ぬことは悲しくてしょうがないんですね
誰だってどんな品物だってワンライフしかないんだよと
思ったら 別に楽しくもないし
悲しくもないんです ああ
そうかで終わっちゃいます
だから 目に見える変化がある
桜島とかね ずっと噴火活火山でしょ
だから変わって変わって変わって変わっていく
おそらくまだまだ今もう誕生しているかもしれませんね
今一つ島も誕生しているでしょ
今結構バカでかくなってますよ
まだまだ海終わってないんです
お産中なんです そこで産んで終わって
火山活動終わったら住めも住めませんよ
まだ赤ちゃんだからね
それでどんどん若い島になってくると
植物も現れてきて そこで先に植物は住むでしょ
それから動物も行って住むでしょ
もうそれからゆっくり後で人間にも住めるようになるんですね
人間が一番後で行くんです
それでやがてその島も老いて亡くなります
この様々な時間というのは
各現象が持っているワンライフのことなんです
これがすごく大事です
だからもう 50歳になったら
もう歯も落ちちゃって
髪の毛もなくなっちゃって
心臓ももうほとんどもう使用期限が切れちゃって
もう無理やりもう伸ばしてるだけで
肺も使用期限が切れちゃってとかね
使用期限も保証期限も全部切れちゃって
それでもうやっと機械にも助けられない時は
50歳で死んじゃったと
だからあまりにも短い人生でしたと言う必要はないんです
何々さんがの人生はあまりにも短かったとかね
長生きできれば その人は長生きしますよ
その人のワンライフは終わったんです
それで子供が白血になったら
そのワンライフは短いんですね
悲しく あっけなく子供が 10歳で死んじゃったではないんです
白血病を持って生まれたんだから
まあワンライフは 10年程度であると
筋ジストロフィーなんとかという病気を持って生まれたら
発病してからはもうだいたい４年 ５
年というんだから で それでもうワンライフワンセットで完了して死ぬんで
誰だって そういう風に見ることができればね
面倒くさいね そんなのは
仏教はそういう風に見るんですね
だから子供が死んでなぜ泣くのかと
で 家が壊れてなぜ泣くのかと
今日  NHK でこの子供たちと一緒のなんとか番組やります
で 授業とかいろんな人がいて
これを見て まあこれは人間の考え方だなと
この福島からね この 避難している子どもたち
インタビューするんですね
で 子どもたちはまあ 来た時はちょこっと寂しかったんだけど
いっぱい友達ができて全然大丈夫と
楽しいんだと言ったら
インタビューする人は嫌な顔をするんですね
じゃあふるさとを思い出せない？とかね
ふるさとを恋しくない？とかね
無理やりに言ったら そうですね
思い出してすごく悲しいですよと
あいつは嘘を言ってるんですね
あるちっちゃな男が なんか哲学者みたいなこんな顔をして
それでこちら来た時は誰のことも知らなくてね
結構きつかったと しかし
どんどんみんな仲良くしてくれる
楽しくなってくるし 友達もいっぱいできちゃって
今はもうしっかり元気でやってますよと
言ったら あんたもうテレビでは出せないとかね
で 嫌な顔するんですね
そこでもう他みんな同じこと言うんだから
結局放送する羽目になっちゃったんです
そこで後半作ってるんですね
後半は この偉い偉い偉い人が
もう相当アホだと思いますけど
だったら日本人にとってすごく偉いでしょ
で この人がこのふるさとを思い出してほしい
ふるさとを恋しくなってほしいとかね
決して忘れるなよと あなた方のふるさとは福島やと
覚えてないんだけど 子どもたちはそんなのは
この人が子供の時間感覚をわかってないんです
そこで あなた方はいくつ年取ったっても
あの覚えてない故郷を思い出してくださいと
悲しく思ってほしいやと
恋しく思ってほしいやと
今はこれからももう 300年経っても立ち入り禁止空間ですけどね
本当は それで自分たちも
自分たちの子どもにも孫たちにも
このメッセージを伝えなくちゃあかんやと
もう決して忘れて この人
何を教えてるんですかね
悲しめ悲しめと 理由がなくても無理でもして悲しめと
私はアルゴ村という村に生まれたんですけど
村というのは自分の好みで
本当はあんまりにも町に近くてね
気持ち悪いんですね だから村だったらいいなというね
で 今全然自分の村という感じがないんです
この年になって あの村にいたのはたった 10年だけでしたから
もう人の顔 人 今人数でいうと誰もわかりません
もういろんな建物を土地が分解して家作ったりしてね
当時の土地の気配もない
だからなんか知らないどこかに行ったような感じで
さっさと用が終わったらすぐ帰りますという気持ちになるんです
私のふるさとということは全くないんですから
だから赤ちゃんを抱っこしてお母さんたちが福島から逃げましたよ
赤ちゃん なんで今泣かなくちゃあかんですか？ふるさとを恋しいとか
そうやってこの変な頭イカれてね
精神的に病気になりなさいよというのは日本国民のメッセージなの
NHK のメッセージなんです
それも NHK の番組で言ったからね
病気になりなさいよと
泣けと 家が潰れたら泣きなさいと
毎回泣きなさいと 毎年私はカメラ持ってくるんだからね
その時またあれを思い出して泣いてくれと
その方が私にとっていい番組撮れますよと
もう本当にびっくりしました
この知恵を与えるところじゃなくてね
もう根本的に無理 犬に算数を教えることと同じなんですね
犬にはお手とかね バーンとかそれぐらい教えられますけどね
お座りとかね よす以外は何もできません
それで無理やりに子供たちに故郷を賛嘆する
詩とか何とか書きなせて
みんなでまあなんとか子供たちもまあ結構結構いいものを書いてあったんですけど
故郷を泣くことではなかったんですね
ただ まあいろんなもうカエルさんのことやら
この今住んでいるところのいろんなことを見てね
何か見たら じゃあこれ文章に取ろうとかね
そうやって文章をまとめてね
生きる喜びを歌っていただけで
だから子供はしっかり頑張っていたんだけど
テレビの番組を作った人の目的と子供たちが発表するものとまるっきり正反対でしたからね
だから子供たちが明るく頑張っていることは嫌で嫌で嫌で
ふるさとを恋しく泣きなさいよと
この連中 ふるさとを知らんんだけど
今住んでいるところがふるさとだから
よくわからない はい そういうことで
このこの我々はこの寿命一個というライフワンライフということで考えたら
結構人生は楽になるんじゃないかなと思います
ユニットを作るのは難しいと
仏教も科学もと同じく
はい これからちょっと休憩取りまして
次に行きます はい 休憩の時間です
ありがとうございます
一番言いたいところは後半に入ります
だから飛ばすしかないでしょう
はい では 次 さらに仏教の時間を考えね
これ 科学者と同じ態度で時間を考えるんですね
全く同じ態度なんです
物質の最初の現象を探すんです
科学者も同じでしょ この原子まで調べて
で 元素を見つけて 元素の原子を見たら原子があって
この原子の中まで見るんですね
で これは仏教では４つのものであると
最終的に出てくるのは
この用語はみんなにわかる地水火風と言ってますけど
本当は土とか何だらかんだらでもないんですね
これだと 四大元素は素粒子
パーティクルのような存在です
この地水火風っていうのは
なんか素粒子４つみたいなもんなんです
あるいはパーティクル４つみたいなもんなんですね
だから素粒子は何かパーティクルなんとかわからない方々は忘れてください
一番小さな単位ですね
で その元素の変化は時間の最初の単位単位です
だから素粒子一個が変わる瞬間が時間の一番短い時間なんですね
だから前に説明したのあの電アトミックトップクロック
電子時計 その素粒子の波長で時間を計算するんです
仏教の時間もその素粒子の波長で計算しているんです
仏教は科学でもないのに
なんでこんなことをやるのか
あれはやっぱり瞑想して知恵を開花すると
物質の波長が見えてくる感じ
ですね そんなに難しいことじゃないんです
だって一番確かにわかるのはそういうものなんです
それから精神の流れをチェックします
仏教は物質ではない 科学ではないんだから
物質科学ではないんだから
この前 昨日ね ずっと疲れ切るまで
私はこの YOUTUBE の英語で
ある仏教の講演をいくつか聞いていたんですね
サイエンスアンドブッディズムというタイトルで
アメリカでミシガン大学やらいくつかのところで講義の講義なんですけど
で ニューロサイエンスアンドブディズムとかね
もういろいろあります
たくさんいろんな大学でね
有名な人々がね そう聞いて
みんな堂々と 仏教っていうのは
仏教と現代のニューロサイエンスとかね
ぴったし合ってるんだと
もう言ってることは全部同じだと
もう言わんばかりで で
もうよーく もう 2500年前にね
もうこういうものもよく発見しましたよとかね
だから見る世界は存在しないんだよと
存在ではなくて ユードンノイというところでね
私も見てびっくり 本当によく科学者の目で見ると
仏教って簡単に説明できるな
この人々のこと これ思いつつも
もう話たくさん聞いて聞いてね
クタクタ疲れてたんです
昨日は そこで彼らも一つ
私がもうずっと言ってることを言っちゃったんですね
仏教っていうのは このキリスト教みたいな宗教ではありませんと
どう見てもものすごく科学との似ているものがありすぎやと
しかし 科学は物質を研究するし
仏教は心を研究しているんだっていう私の言葉そのまま先生は私からパクったわけじゃないと思いますからね
だから調べれば誰でも同じことを言うだろうと思ったんですね
そういうわけで 仏教が物質の素粒子の波長で時間計算するんじゃなくて
それも調べてから精神の波長を見るんですね
一つの心が次の心に変わる時間は
精神の最初の時間単位です
一つの心が次の心に変身する
その間が時間の最初の単位
それであの精神の最小の時間単位になります
仏教の時間のユニット
心が別な心に変化する時間は瞬かなと言うんですね
秒ではないんです 仏教は心理学なので
瞬を基準にします だから
この心が次の心に移る時間
一瞬です 一瞬というのは
一瞬の何兆も過ぎたら 1 秒ぐらいになるんです
すごい小さな時間なんです
一瞬は ナノ秒でもないんです
はい これでちょっとわかりやすいことを言います
アバウトで言えば 物質の瞬は心の 17 瞬長いんです
いわゆる電波 電気 電子時計の 1 秒の 100分の1
チェックしているでしょ？ 100分の1やってます
人間の目に見えませんだけどね
これ  1 秒の 100分の1で出してますから
うーん それは心の瞬で稼ぐと 17 倍長いんです
物質の場合はのんびりなんです
心早いんです これ もっと我々にわからないんだから
私はこう言うんです 光の速度より心は 17 倍早く変化しますよと
だから速度というのはどうやって計算するかよくわかりませんだけどね
一つの光子が動くスピードですからね
この動くスピードは時間と関係ないんだけど
変化するんですね そういうことで
まあ次に行きます 仏教の時間単位は
五感の情報に依存している一般の人々の心で把握できないんです
だから我々には一瞬っていうのはわからないんですよ
我々は目で見えるもので
耳で聞こえるもので考えているんだからね
何か見るためには結構時間が必要ですよ
例えば まぶたを閉めて開けて閉めたら見えません
何も 例えば今もまぶたを閉じているでしょ？閉じても真っ暗にならないでしょ
だからもう結構鈍 この目が
耳も すごくノロノロ動いているんです
大量に光がぶつけて結構重くならない限り神経が反応しないんです
目の神経細胞がたくさんデータがぶん殴ってぶん殴っても
いていてどころになったら信号が脳に行って
脳でまたのんびりプロセッシングして見えたことにするんです
そうっともうノロノロなんです
仏教が教えている瞬っていうのはそんなもんじゃないんです
だから我々には把握できない
そういうわけで 幻覚の世界というテーマに入ります
桜も山も豆腐も我が家も地球も大宇宙も同じスピードで変化していきます
だってすべて素粒子でできているでしょ
原子は様々だけど 素粒子といえばどんな原子の中でも素粒子は同じなんです
そこでの量子力学なんとかあるでしょ
このクォンタムフィジックスというね
これ アインシュタインさんが大嫌いでしたからね
アインシュタインさんがすべて一定の法則にまとめられると思っていたんですね
だから神様はこのあれ
ダイスを ダイスって何でしたっけ？ゴッドダイスという言葉がありましたけど
え？サイコロ 遊びしないんだと
いわゆるワンパターン
あれが破れちゃったんですね
クォンタムフィジックスを学んだところで
もういい加減ですね 素粒子たちが
法則を見つからなかったんです
その読めない 予測できないということは
いつだって世の中にあるんです
予測できない それがクォンタムフィジックスから成り立っているんです
素粒子たちが何するかと
こちらの計算ではできない
問題は素粒子ではなくて
原子やら物質で ニュートンさんの法則で科学成り立っちゃったんだから
本当はそれは成り立たないだけなんです
最初からもう素粒子の仕組みを見て科学作った方がよかったのではないかなと
で それできなかったんだからね
だからこれが不確定やって言って
それは不確定じゃないんだ
本当は あのクォンタムフィジックで言ってる
あの不確定っていうのは不確定じゃないんです
ニュートンの法則から見ると不確定だけであって
本当はそちらの法則はあるんです
だから仏教の場合は その世界から物質数学
物理学が始めちゃったんだから
誰にもわからないことになっているんです
ニュートンさんのことはほとんど考えてないんです
その立場から見てください
富士山は素粒子でできているんです
素粒子の変化スピードは同じです
桜の素粒子でできているんです
桜の素粒子も同じスピードで変化しているんです
瞬間瞬間で 私の家もこの体も素粒子でできているんです
だから同じスピードで変化しているんです
心が瞬間瞬間で変化する
体が瞬間の十七回 十七回で変化しているんですね
しかし 私たちから見れば
富士山はもう何百万年もいてとかね
桜はたった三日やと なんて悲しいかって状態でしょ
だから富士山が長生きするんだ
桜の花は三日間だけや
我が家はせいぜい四十年やっていうのは幻覚の世界です
本当の世界じゃないんです
しかし 私たちにはそれは認識できません
日本という国は遠い昔からあったのです
これから遠い未来まであることでしょう
以上は立派な幻覚です
だから日本国の歴史っていうのはね
人間が現れる前からでしょ
結構長生きしたんですね
これからあんなの幻覚です
桜の桜の花が早く散っちゃったっていうのはね
たった二日 三日で散った
幻覚です すべて同じスピードで変化していくんです
これが認識できないんだから
勝手に作った幻覚で落ち着いて満足しているんです
次 たちの悪い幻覚があります
あの富士山は長生きしますよと
私はそこまでないやっていうのは幻覚ですけど
まあしょうがないんですね
たちが悪いと言えないでしょ
たちの悪い幻覚があります
それは私がいるということ
私がいる これ最悪の幻覚です
永遠の魂がある 永遠の命
永遠の天国 自我の存在などの幻覚は
幻覚というより精神的な不治の病です
病気です 心の命は一瞬です
それは私 あなたの命の長さでもあります
はい ここからポイントです
私がいるんだっていうのは
私に心があるんだからでしょ
手があるんだからじゃないでしょ
足があるんだからじゃないでしょ
手足がなくても心があったら私がいるんですね
目があるんだからじゃないでしょ
両目もなくなっても 心があれば私がいるんです
例えば認知症で知識がなくなっても
何々さんがいるんですね
本人にも私がいるという気持ちがあるんです
あなたの名前は忘れています
名前を忘れているんだけど
自分がいるということは知っていますね
だから私がいるとは 私の心があるということでしょ
心の寿命は瞬間です この瞬間がどれぐらい短いんですか？長いんですかね
光よりも十七倍速いんです
もう死んでるんです だから私というと
私 文字３つでしょ もしかすると六兆回死んで生まれているんです
わというと二兆回 二兆瞬ですね
二兆です すごいでしょう
生まれて死んで 生まれて死んで
生まれて死んで だから何に私と言うんですかね
ただストリームだけなんですね
流れる はい それでこのスライドに書いてないんだけど
一つポイント聞きます
年聞いたらすぐ言うでしょ？人に言わなくても自分で知ってるでしょ
では気持ちで聞いてみてください
自分の心に心が何歳ですかと
心は何歳でもありません
肉体から聞くと 68 とか 69 とか 70 とか言いますけど
やはり心は 心に時間年言えないんです
だから永遠不滅と勘違いで
それが だって年と言ったっても
時間の最小単位で死んでるんだから
死んで新しい心なんです
新しい生命なんです 新しい生命という言わいがもうまた新しい生命なんです
だから誰にも精神的には年っていうことは感じないんです
体見ると頭見ると結構老げて
もう年なんですけど 気持ちはただ私がいる
それだけ私がいる それで終わる
だからこれで心はいかに早く変化するのかっていうことは事実であって
宗教の人々は頭が悪かったんだから
だから私がずっと永遠にいるんだよと
変化しない魂があるんだよと
ものすごい質の悪い幻覚を作っちゃったんですね
幻覚ではなくて あれはもう最悪質の悪い幻覚を作っちゃったんです
はい 手記の時間感が消えたらどうなるのかと
あなたは自分で自分のために作った刑務所から出られます
私たちは私たちのために時間を作ったんです
時間という妄想を 観念を
これが刑務所になって永久的に閉じ込められていじめている
いじめられているんです
いじめを受けているんです
時間観念がなくなったら刑務所が壊れます
入っていたくてももうできないんです
はい ちょっと遊びしましょう
5 分で自分が死ぬと思ってみて
驚く 困る 真面目に思ってください
あと 5 分で死にますと
で 悩む 怖い 失神する あんた 5 分で死にますよと言われたら
医者が 3 年後って言っただけで失神しますからね
一部の人は この永遠に死ねないと思っている人
そのようになります 我は永遠に死ぬわけないと思ってる人が
あんた 3 年で死にますよと言われると驚く
困る 悩む 怖いと思う 失神する
皆様どちらになります？聞かないことにします
あんた５分で死にますよって言ったら驚いちゃったら
困ったらね 怖くなったらこのグループなんです
しかし もう一つグループがいるんです
理性で見ると ５分で死ぬ ５
分で死ぬか 理性で見ると
困ることは一切消える
だって５分しかないんだから
別にいいんじゃない？それで
困らないこともいいでしょう ５
分ぐらいはもうなんとかなります
だから今まであったすべての悩み
苦しみが消えるんです
例えば貯金はどうしようとかね
あと 500 万ぐらいあれば
あと 1,000 万ぐらい貯金があればよかったとかね
ないでしょ 年金もらえるかどうでもいいでしょ
もう 消費税がね どんどんこれ10%までどうでもいいでしょ
あんたにとってはもう５分で死ぬんだから
北朝鮮が原発でも日本に向けて撃っちゃいます
どうして？いい加減にしろよと
すべて消えるでしょ 子供のことで悩んでいるとか
孫のことでとか あんた何したいんですか？どうにもならん
もう５分だけやと だから今まであった苦しみっていうのは
あの心配事っていうのはサーッと消えるんですよ
私が５分しか生きてられませんとわかったら
仕事も家族も これ何でしたっけ？書いたんだけど
忘れちゃった 読み方は
しわがあることも 貯金がないことも
ダイエットの心配もすべてなくなります
あーダイエットしなくちゃあかんとかね
あ ケーキ食べてはいけませんとか
ハンバーグ食べてはいけ
どうでもいいでしょ もう５分で死ぬんだから
ケーキを食っちゃっても
ハンバーグ食っちゃっても
食わなくたってもどうでもいいことで
この 5 分間で完全に生きようとします
そうではなくて じゃあこの 5 分間でね
しっかりやっちゃえと
好きな人も嫌いな人もどうでもいいことになっちゃうんです
あの人のことを嫌いやとかね
どうでもいいでしょ ５
分だけだから そんなのは
あの人は好きだけど 放っておき
どうでもいいんだからね
どうにもならんやつ 好きであっても ５
分だけだからね 怒ること
嫉妬すること 恨むことなどに何の意味がありますかと
たった５分だけであんたのことを恨みますとかね
恨んで恨んで恨みにふけって
この 5 分間生きるとかね
やる？やらない 言葉で言い表せない自由
安らぎ 解放感を感じるでしょうと ５
分で死ぬんだよと 仏教のこの死随念という死に従って念じる瞑想がありまして
このすごい安らぎを感じるために彼を教えているんです
誰もやってないんだけどね
神様に祈るだけで もしあなたが1万年生きられるとしたらどうなります？ 1万年かけて計画を立てなくちゃあかんですよ
あんなプレハブみたいな家に住める
ボードで貼って 壁を壁紙をちょっと指で触っただけでつぶれる壁紙でいいと思いますかね
1万年生きてるならば
壁紙はダメでしょう 壁にしっかりデザイナーが作ったタイルを貼らなくちゃあかんですよ
大理石とか 冗談じゃないんです
金を儲けなくては 石で家を建てなくてはということになるでしょう
体が壊れないようにしなくては
だって壊れたらどうする？だって1万年いるんだから
ちょこっと失敗して足が折っちゃったらどうする？1万年間も足がなく生活する羽目になるんだから
だから足が怪我しないしないようにと守らなくちゃ大変なことになるんです
ちょっと不注意なことで目が見えなくなっちゃうと
これから一年一万年間どうする？だから大事に目も守らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
認知症になったら  1万年寿命で考えてください
土地 財産 親戚 家族などに執着しなくてはならない
この家族と長生きしなくちゃあかんやと
だから頑張らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
長生きするなら退屈でたまらないんですよ
それから音楽があっても
毎回毎回毎回 百年も百年も聴いてるんだから
退屈でたまらん 映画見てももう古い映画見てください
ものすごく超つまらないです
だって同じことだから
テーマは同じだから あの NHK の朝ドラみたいに
毎年まるっきり同じドラマでしょ
全部フォーマット決まっていて
これが皆様にとってはね
まあ一回の寿命だから
あのまあ朝ドラ見る人々も決まっていて
そこでまあ年取って死んじゃいますからね
もし百年二百年生きる人なら
何年朝ドラ見られると思います？五年続けたらもう絶対見たくないってことになるんです
だから一万年生きる人にとってはもうむちゃくちゃ人生退屈なんです
それで私は何を言いたいんですかというと
五分で死ぬと思ったらものすごい幸せが来るのに
あなたの寿命は一万年生きられます
生きますようにと 生きられますようにと
神様でもなんとかからくりやったら
あれほど不幸がないんです
あれは耐えられないんです
ものすごい苦しみが 限りなく苦しみが生まれてくる
ちょっとでも怪我したっても困る
ちょっと物覚えがどんどん忘れていっちゃうと困る
困る それでは 大量に貯金がなかったら困るわ
困るわ そういうことでみんな喜んで永遠不滅になりたいでしょうに
どうぞなってください
キリスト教になってください
幸せを与えてくれる そんな幸せなんです
正しく見ると だからああいうのはこの愚か者の人々の考えなんですね
実は五分もありませんよ
あなたの命にはと 本当のところ
私とは肉体ではありません
心があるから私です その心は瞬間で死ぬのです
心があるから私です この心は瞬間で死ぬんです
5分もてません 次の瞬間は別な心です
だから別人です 固定した私と指すべき何かはありません
これ私ですと指すものはないんです
勢いで光の速度で死んでいくんです
はい それわかったら智慧の世界
瞬間論わかったら 瞬間論は人間の常識では理解不可能です
集中して現象を観察すると発見する真理です
瞬間の変化を見えたら
自我の錯覚が消えてしまいます
あのタチの最悪 タチの悪い幻覚が消えます
あの我々のタチの悪い幻覚が世間で生きるために一応残りますけど
幻覚は幻覚だと知っています
自我の錯覚が消えてしまいます
時間という刑務所が壊れます
心は瞬間だと 命とは瞬間のものだと
結局何もないんだと 執着に値するものは何もないんだと
わかったら刑務所が壊れます
欲 怒り 嫉妬 恨みなどの煩悩のよりどころがなくなってしまいます
もう土台がなくなっちゃった
自我があって怒るんです
自我があって欲張るんです
自我があって恨むんです
自我があって悩むんです
いつでも主語が私がなんです
私が怒っている 私があなたを恨んでいるとかね
タチの悪い錯覚ですね
いるわけないんです 私は
たった瞬間のあなたですからね
悩み 苦しみも成り立たなくなります
だって悩む なんで悩むんですかね
悩める暇がないでしょう
もう死んでる 新しい命だから
悩まないんです それで苦しまないんです
心は完全に自由を経験するんです
すべて束縛がなくなって
だからこの瞬間とは何だとわかれば
ヴィパッサナー瞑想っていうのはそれを目指してやらせているんです
瞬間瞬間 ものは消える
消える 消える 消える とそれわかったら
次の瞬間に悟りに出します
今の瞬間のみに集中して生きることにします
だから 悟りに達した人は
まあまだ肉体があるんだから生きてますけど
今の瞬間だけに集中して
明日は関係ない 明後日は関係ない
昨日は関係ないということでしっかりできるんです
これが覚者の生き方ですね
だから時間論というのは
仏教の時間論というのは
そうやって瞬間論に成り立って悟りに達する世界なんです
すべての悩み苦しみを壊しちゃって
超えて 究極の安らぎを感じる世界なんです
仏教の時間論は はい これで講演は終わりましたから
何といいますか 後の言葉でいきます
時間はあなたを責めないという
時間に追われるという
それは壁が飛んできて頭にぶつかったというような話ですよ
この壁が飛んできて 私の頭にぶつかっちゃったんだから
すごい大きなしまったと
何言ってるんですかね
アホおかしいでしょ だったら時間に追われると言うてはいけませんよ
存在しないんです 時間は
山が勝手に回ってあなたを遭難させたと
山が回りませんよ あなたが勝手に回ったから遭難したんです
山に入って あなたいい加減にあっちに行ったりこっちに行ったりして
もうもうもうわからなくなっちゃって
迷子になっちゃって 遭難してしまっちゃったんです
山が何もやってないんですよ
しかし 我々へっちゃらで言うでしょ
この山は危険だ 迷子になるんだとかね
なんか山が悪いみたいよ
自分の不注意で頭壁にぶつかって
もうもうもう頭にもうもうなんて言いますか
割れ目まで入っちゃうとね
この壁は危険だ とんでもないやつへっちゃらで言うでしょ
あなたが走ったから壁にぶつかっただけです
時間観はあなたが作ったんです
時間という妄想概念を
それも正しい時間観ではなかったのです
あなた 時間を妄想しました
それも正しい妄想ではなかった
私は思ったのだから それは必ず存在すると勘違いしているんです
これはあります なんで私がそう思ったんだから
いや そんなこと言うんだから
時間がありますよ なんで時間があるとは私は思ってるんだから
だったらペガサスもいますよ
怪獣もいますよ だって世の中で幽霊がいるわ
お化けがいるわ お化け屋敷があるわとかね
世の中でもいっぱいもう迷信あるでしょうに
昔はね 義母さんなんとかっていう女がいてね
霊能者でテレビで出るわ出るわで結構金儲けてと思いますけど
今は地獄に喜んでるでしょうね
あの 例えば このフランスの歴史とか
ある場所に連れて行くんですね
そこで首を切られて死んじゃった
なんとかなんとかマリアなんとかなんとか言っちゃったんですね
そこでこちらで逮捕されて何年いたとかね
こちらで首を切られたとか
いろんな場所がある どちらにいたっても
この人にこの霊能で見えるんですね
あ マリアアナトさんがこの刑務所で
なんで私はこんなところにいるの？と悲しがっているんだと
そこで首を切ったところに行ったら
すごく怖くて怯えて 首を切られたまんまでまだいるんだと
霊魂何体あるんですかね
あの人と だから日本人がそれを信じるんだからいいんだけど
まとめて だから外国で英訳でもして放送しちゃったら
日本人がみんな精神病気
病院に連れて行かなくちゃ思っちゃうんですよ
だからもうくだらんことをこんなこと言うんだからね
これで金儲かってるんだから
また 面白いんですよ それで私が言いたいのは
人の非難ではなくて 我々は妄想したんだからといって
その品物はあるわけないんですよ
ペガ ペガサスは描けますよ
だって馬見たことがある
鳥の翼が見たことがある
合わせればいいんだから
そこで面白いことに あのペガサスの絵
描いてる絵を見てください
イラスト みんな大きな間違いしているんです
バカバカらしくて で 翼は綺麗に描くんですよ
美しい翼が これはいいんです
しかし この体を支えるための翼だったら
あのジャンボ機のあの翼ぐらいでないとね
馬の だって力学的に力学というんですか？このできないでしょ？あの翼ではね
はい そこは一つの問題で
翼が小さすぎ だからでっかい翼を描いて小さな馬を描かないと
まず一つ 次 馬の足を見てください
ペガサスの 馬っていうのは走る時美しいんですよ
馬は走る動物だからね
走るマシンだからね なんでも美しいんだよ
馬走る時は そこで空を飛ぶ馬
馬の足が美しく走る時の足なんです
あの空飛べませんよ あんな足のつけ方で
だから足をきちっと体につけてもらわないと
そう書いてないでしょ
私が言いたいのは 妄想するのか
いい加減もうちょっとマシなことを妄想しなさいと
妄想するならば もっとマシなことを妄想しなさいと
はい まあそれはどうでもいいんですけど
この怪獣も描いたりするでしょ
どう見ても科学的に成り立っていない怪獣ばっかりで
それは人間の遊びだから認めますけど
ペガサスのこと 人間の遊びだからね
これはいいんだけど だからといってマジそれいると思う？怪獣がマジでいると思うんだったら病気でしょ
だからそういうところから考えて
時間っていうのは私が勝手に作った観念であって
時間そのものは存在すると思ったところで
あなたの失敗で間違いなんです
自分が作った観念が獣になって自分を襲うというと思っているんです
だから時間に追われているという
あの圧迫感 あのストレスは自分で作ったものなんです
その上怠けるんです もう頭が悪いということもわかったでしょ
その上怠けるんです 無知な人の心に時間は無限です
だって時間考えたら無限と思っちゃうでしょ
それでどうなるかというと
人は死んでも自分が死なない
死ぬはずもないという
としっかり信じ込んでいるんです
皆様も私もみんな人間
そうなんですよ 我は死なないという前提で生きているんです
ものすごいおかしいんです
5 分で死ぬんだと思ったら
あれほど幸せなのに 瞬間で死ぬんだと思ったら
極度に幸せなのに 手抜きするために
怠けるために 良いチャンスです
それは だって死ぬわけないんだからね
それで後でします 明日にします
という生き方に陥るんです
これって怠けなんです
そんな暇がないんです
時間たっぷりありますから
後でしましょうよと 明日しましょうよと
これは無知 仕事後回しにする
それで世界はそうじゃないんです
後で何もできません 明日にすることは全く不可能です
これわかってないんです
怠けることは不可能です
本当は法則から見れば
だから法則に逆らって怠けようとするということは
やるべきことをやらないことにする
でも その人がもう死んじゃうんです
その代わりに生まれた新しい人間なんです
その人は死んだ人の過ちの結果を受ける羽目になるんです
今の瞬間の私が怠けたら仕事をしてないでしょ
次の瞬間に生まれた私にとっては
あの罰が全部来るんです
それは無知な人の怠けというんですね
今の瞬間にやるべきことをやらない
今の今日のことは決して明日することはできません
もうできませんよ 過ぎ去った瞬間は永久的に来ない
再生しない だったら今日も花見に行けるでしょ
行けないでしょ もう終わったんだから
人生は本番のみ 人生にはリハーサルはありません
どんな瞬間も本番です
失敗したら次の瞬間で後悔する
後悔するから 次の瞬間にやるべきこともできなくなります
だから人生は本番のみなんです
今の瞬間にやるべきことをやっておいてください
瞬間だけのことだから
どうしたってもできることなんです
これしなかったら 次の瞬間で後悔する
それでどうなるかというと
次の瞬間でやる仕事はやってないんです
次の瞬間 後悔することに費やしちゃったんです
大変なことになるんです
あんた 前の瞬間の仕事もしなかった
次の瞬間で仕事をすればよかったのに
次の瞬間後悔しちゃったって
また仕事をしなかったと
そうすると 3番目の瞬間どうなる？なおさら後悔する
次にさらに後悔する 立派でしょ
この生き方は 怠け者の
徐々に悪化していく 苦しくなっていく悪循環が現れてくるのです
このように人間が苦の循環を作っているのです
その苦の循環も 苦がどんどん大きくなっていくのです
時間に責められると思っている人は立派な怠け者です
もし誰かがもう時間に責められてもうイライラと言ったら
ものすごい怠け者なんです
そんなはずがないんです
自分の無知に酔っているだけです
あれは無知に酔ってるんです
人を言わせる感情 だから無知だけじゃない
無知は基本 ものすごい麻薬的な力があるんです
無知で仕事をしない やるべきことをしない
そこでやるべきことは溜まってくる
同時に後悔も溜まってくる
やったって っても昨日やらなくちゃあかんものだから
今日やっても意味がない
だから自分が頑張っても頑張っても
本当に人生は無駄ばっかりだと無茶なことを言う
そういう生き方をしているんです
それは無知に酔ってるんです
無知だけじゃないんですよ
言うのはね 欲 怒り 嫉妬などの無数の感情が現れます
何でも麻薬効果があります
時間があるという錯覚から煩悩が起こります
だから時間があるということから
あらゆる煩悩が起こります
だから時間がないという風に思わなくちゃあかんのです
存在もしないんだと 感情が人を酔わせるんです
だって怒りが出てきたら仕事をしないでしょ
勉強しないでしょ 嫉妬が出てきたら仕事をしないでしょ
後回しにするでしょ 酔った人は今のことを後回しにする
これが苦の悪循環と言います
はい お釈迦様はどういう教えるのかと
ある日 命は瞬間瞬間に消えていく
生まれたものは必ず死ぬ
しっかりと修行に励みなさいと弟子たちにお釈迦様が説かれます
かなり直截で言ったんです
これを経典を読んだ時も
私もちょっとびっくりして
ちょっと恐怖感を感じたんだから
すごい力でと 昨日もちょっと読んでみたんです
その時 マーラ いやしきもの
マーラっていうのは悪魔っていう意味なんですけど
悪魔とも言いますけど
悪魔ではないんです 釈尊に告げます
マーラは俗世間の一般人の意見を述べる役柄です
だから仏教のマーラっていうのは世間の考えなんです
こうマーラの言葉 ナーチャヤンティアホラッタジーヴィタンヌーパルッジャティ アーユアヌパーリヤーヤティマッチャーナンネーミワラッラタクッバランと
結構かっこいい歌ですよ
これは まあ歌えますけど
やめます もし私の美しい声に見とれたら困りますからね
もう疲れてる時はね 日夜は消えない
命はなくならない なんかこれ馬鹿馬鹿しい感じるでしょ？じゃないんです
日夜 日夜 日夜 日夜 無限でしょ
だから生きる 生きる 生きる
無限やと そんなのはと
人の寿命は減るのではない
みんな生きる 生きる 生きる
生きる 生きるだけやと
車輪が軸を回るようにとたとえまで出してるんですね
確かに馬車の車輪が回ってますよ
でも終わりがないでしょ
回るわ 回るわ 回るわ 回るわ回るわ
まあどこまででも回るでしょうに
だから落ち着いて楽しくまあ死にそうにしないんだよとマーラが言うんですよ
人生楽しめよと 永遠だと
命はと これは皆様と世間とマーラが同じことを言ってるんです
お釈迦様はアッチャヤンティアホラッタジーヴィタンウパルッジャティ
アーユキーヤティマッチャーナンクンナディンナミワスオーダカン クンナディーナンワオーダカン
あ そう間違った アッチャヤンティアホラッタジーヴィタンウパルッジャティ
アーユキーヤティマッチャーナンクンナディーナンワオーダカン
ってお釈迦様の歌なんですね
日夜は過ぎ去る 毎日同じことじゃないんですよ
二度と来ないんです だって
宇宙から見ても 太陽系そのもの動いてるでしょ
毎日同じところで公転してるわけじゃないんです
命は減る 命っていうのは
人の寿命は減っていくんだと
小川の水の様にちっちゃな小川があったら
ちょっとしたことで水が全部なくなっちゃいますよと
だから時間がないんだよと
すぐ頑張りなさいっていうのはブッダの言葉なんです
と 仏教はの時間論を語られたんです
それは仏教の時間論なんです
ということで 話を省略します
ありがとうございます
...今日はありがとうございました
人間関係での質問です
えっと ある人と付き合って
で この人はちょっと道徳的に悪影響があるなと判断して
少しちょっと距離を置くとか
縁を切ろうとかっていうふうに考えることがつい最近あったんですけれども
今日のお話もちょっと関連して
人を判断するとか あと過去にあった出来事では
これは良くないなっていうことと
その相手に対するその慈悲の心と
あとそのお釈迦様のお言葉で
その悪友とは愚か者とは付き合うなという言葉の
そのまあバランスというか
考え方がまだちょっといまいち自分の中ではっきりとしていないので
教えていただけると幸いです
はい これは座ったまんまで答えられませんね
あのね 私たちはこのいつだって時間も自分が作ったものと同じで
自分が作った世界にいるんですね
だから自分が作った世界で
この人はちょっとやばい
この人はいいとか自分で判断するんですね
だからいつだって刑務所は自分で作るんですよ
それで できれば判断しない方が正しいんだけどね
まだまだ私たちはそこまでできてないんだからね
だからこうしましょう
この人が悪人ですではなくて
この人のことを悪人のように感じていますと
私の考えでは 私には悪人で見える
私には道徳を守ってない人のように見える
という風に責任を持ってください
あの判断しない方が理性的で正しいんだけど
まだまだそこまではね
無理 できてないんだからいいんです
あの人は可愛いなと思って構わない
構いません しかし その時も私には可愛く見える
そこでこのしっかりした人間として
理性のある人間として自分に責任を持つんです
これって簡単でできます
このラーメン美味しいよではなくて
私は食べたところで私にはすごく美味しかったよと
そうするとものすごい別世界が見えてくるんです
あのお店のラーメンはもう世界一品で美味しいよって言ってはあかん
あれが愚か者の言い方ですね
私は何々店でラーメン食べたんだけど
あれがものすごく美味しく感じましたよと
聞いてる人が行って食べてまずかったと言ったっても
こちらの責任じゃないんです
私が進んだら あのね  店のラーメンは世界一逸品だからね
あなたもせめて一度でも行って食ってくださいと言ったところで
この人も 4時間並んで
朝 6時からね 昼のラーメン食べるってね
で 食べたら全然ダメでしたと
美味しくなかったら怒ってくるでしょう
電話で あのね あんた言ったところで
この間ね ラーメン食べたんだけど
ここまで苦労してね あれどうかなってるんだと
なんだ あれは とかね えらいことになるでしょ
だから我々はそういう失敗してます
だからこうします 私は食べたんだけど
食べてみたらものすごく美味しかったと
あの味が私にとって忘れられない味ですよと
はい それで終わり 聞いた馬鹿がまた同じラーメン食ったら
その人の責任なんです
それでその人はこちらに電話かけてきて
カンカン怒って なんであんなことを言うんでしょうかと
あのね これ私に美味しかったと言ったよと
あなたに行けと言ってないんだと
私は無茶苦茶するならばね
訴えてやるぞと 関係ないことで
ということまで言える
それは冗談で大げさに言っただけで
そういうふうにしてください
これぐらいは誰にでもできます
これは私の気持ち これ私の考えというふうな態度で
だから自分の気持ちで
この人は道徳を守ってないというふうにわかったら
それで私がそう思っていて
本人がどう思っているか知ったことではありません
この本人の友達はどう思っているか知ったことではありません
と私から見れば道徳を守っていないように見える
だから私がそれに合わせて対応するということになるんですね
別な例を言いましょうか
あるところで ものすごく体格のいい
見たらきれいだなと思う
でっかい牛がいる そこで
その牛を飼っている人が来てね
これが私の息子みたいな
かわいくてかっこいいでしょう
本当に 性格もいいでしょうとかね
あれこれやとか言って大人しいよとかね
言ったところで こちらもアホで言って牛を触ろうとしたら
もうこれでそれでやっちゃったらどうする？だからそれってわからないことなんですね
だからまあ この牛さんはどんな人間触っても何ともしないよと言ったら
まあ自分も人間の一人だから触ってみるとかね
だからライオンを飼っている人でも
飼育係の人にとっては
動物園ではあまりやらないんだけど
触ったりじゃれたりすることはできますよ
ライオンと虎はね 猫だから
もともと で 動物園ではできるだけ自然に近い形というくだらんなことを考えているんだから
動物園何の自然もないんだけどね
もうあまりじゃれたりはしませんだけど
飼育係は もし人がライオンとじゃれて付き合っているんだからって
あなたもいきなり行く？ライオンじゃん
可愛い可愛いとか だからそこら辺なんですね
我々考えるのは だから
私にとって道徳を守らない人がライオンなんですね
ちょっと近寄らない方がいい
やばい しかし ライオン同士ではじゃれたっても
それは関係ないんですよ
はい そこまで 次のポイントは
この悪人をカットしなさいとね
ブッダの言葉なんですね
これはこういうことなんですね
自分が精神的に弱くて
人の影響が何でもいいんだから受けるばかりだったら
気をつけるしかないんです
自分で責任を持っていて
私は影響を受ける場合は自分で選ぶんだよと
いうところまで成長しているならば
悪人の問題はそれほど出てこないんです
はい この方の影響は受けます
あなたの影響は絶対受けません
それだったら一緒にいることもできます
とは言っても だいたいあまりにも悪人で
あまりにも波長が悪くて
嫉妬 怒り 憎しみなどなどの人々をできるだけ避けた方がいいんです
なぜかというと 心っていうのはいつでも元気でしっかりと自己管理できないんです
時々我々は自分のガードを緩めるんです
その時はどんどんあのエネルギーが入ってくるんです
だから 一応念のために悪人を一般の方々は避ける
しかし それが法則ではありません
もしお釈迦様が悪人を避けたならば
どうなる？お釈迦様から見れば
お釈迦様だけ悟りに達して
みんな汚れた頭の悪い人々でしょ
で 避けてないないんですね
みんな育ててあげたんですよ
人殺しなところも行くんです
相手が人殺しなんですけど
相手が犯罪者なんです
お釈迦様は行くんです
だから人格できた人はには悪人
善人という考えあまりない
人を判断しない 行為が悪いんだったら
あのね あなたがこれやってることが悪いよと客観的に言うんです
これやったらこの結果になると
しかし どの場合は悪人がどうしてもこの精神的なパワーがある人の影響を受けて良くなります
はい そこは話で まあ適当にご自分に合わせて頑張ってみてください
はい  他に質問ある方挙手していただければ
では 中段のいらっしゃいますか
本日はお話いただきまして
どうもありがとうございました
お聞きしたいのは心の病についてですね
親しい人が潔癖症というもので悩んでおられます
何かあると全てを洗ったりとか
綺麗にしなくてはいけないとかということで苦しんでおられます
で これについて 2つ質問があります
一つは これは仏教の観点から見ると
どういうような心の病なのか
2つ目は このような苦しんでいる人に対してどのような声をかけてあげたらいいのか
良くなるような何か接し方があればアドバイスいただきたいと思います
うん あの仏教から見れば
それはもう当然精神的な病気ですけど
あの自我ですね 自我と妄想の結果
全部精神病気はそれ 2つです
難しくないんです どんな精神病であっても
自我と妄想 だからその人は自我がありすぎちゃって
それから妄想して世界が汚いと
何考えている 魚がね 水は汚い
水では潰れたくないと思っていること
水の中にいるんだから
魚が 我々は世界の中にいるんだから
自分の肉体も世間の一部だからね
成り立たないんだけど
そういう人が自我がありすぎちゃって
錯覚を起こしてるんですね
妄想しちゃって 我は私はきれい
外が汚いと だからもうこれは本当に生きづらい病気で
友達も作れないし 結婚もできないしね
大変なんです それであの田んぼで田植えして
あるいは稲刈りしたりして
むっちゃ楽しくなり楽しくなりたいんだったら
裸足で入ってください
田んぼに あのブーツを履かないで
むっちゃ楽しいんですよ
泥だらけで体中泥で それでも田植えをする
稲刈りの場合は危険だから手袋程度で
それも危険だからっていうだけであってね
そうやってもう泥まみれっていうのはえらい気持ちいいんですよ
一緒になるんだから 世界とね
すごい気持ちいいんです
まあ子供はやってますからね
いくらお母さんがきれいな服を着せちゃってもね
あっという間に汚しちゃうんです
あれ 意図的に汚すんです
汚した方が気持ちいいんです
はい そこでそういう人にどんな言葉をかけてかければいいかということで
短い言葉がありましてね
あなたはいくら潔癖でいようと思ったっても
あなたは他の人より不潔やと
体もね だからこれはまあペンギン飛ぼうとすることと同じやと
だから自分でそう思っても
私から見ればあなたはすごい
あの汚くて汚い人間だと見えてくるんだよと
正直に言ってみて 正直でなくてもいいんだけど
うん そうね あなたのわかるんだけど
でも私から見たとて あなたはものすごく気持ち悪くてね
不潔で感じるんだよと
言うと 本人がなんとか何かショックを受けたりするんですよ
それで喧嘩になってもいいんです
まああなたも不潔 私も
だから何ですかと そういうことで
いくらか まあ結局はみんな不潔やというふうに感じになりますよ
そういうふうに周りのも
あなたも相当不潔なやつですねとかね
言われると自分が無駄をやってるということに気づく可能性あります
可能性だけ これはすばりということじゃないんです
正しい仏教的な答えは
体は本来汚い 不浄 不浄なものであると
この洗っても洗っても不浄やと
体から出るものは全部汚いものやと
尿やら大便やら汗やら唾液やら鼻水
鼻くそとかね 耳くそとか
何かきれいなもの出るかと
だからクソの工場やと
あなたクソ工場を持ってるんだよと
それがブッダの言葉なんですね
クソ工場やと これはと
だから潔癖症にならんですよ
ではどうしますかというと
心は美しく 怒りなく 嫉妬なく
欲なく 恨みなく 思いやりのある
慈しみのある心は持てよと
美しい花が咲くように
心に美しい心が美しい花にしようと
心がきれいだったらすべて美しいやとということで
あのね 肉体ではなく 心を磨けと
心をきれいにしなさいっていうのは仏教の戒めなんです
サチッタパリヨダパナ
クリーンナップユアマインドなんです
クリーンアップユアボディではないんです
肉体を洗えではないんです
心を洗えと と教えているんです
はい  まだ時間でありますけど
では  本日はありがとうございます
先ほど 5 分で生きると考えることで
いろんな煩悩もなくなって
心が自由になるというお話がありましたけれども
そういうふうに限りがある短い命というふうに考えるとですね
逆に空しくなったりとか
生きる気力を失ったりとか
そういう方向にも心が向いてしまいそうな気がするのですが
そこら辺はどういうふうに考えてよろしいでしょうか
はい だから 2種類いると言ったでしょ
最初から 私が永遠だと思っているグループと
ただ理性であ そうかいというね
思う人々をね 例えば雪が降ったら困った困った
なんでこんなに異常現象と困るバカもいて
ああ そうか 今日はそういうものかと思って落ちつく人間もいるでしょ
だからどうしても 2種類いるんです
だからどうしようもない
これはね だから我は永遠やっていうとこはあまりにもバカバカしくてかっこ悪いと思うならば
いくらか勉強して勉強して
ブッダが教えた真理を学んで
理性のカテゴリーに入れてもらわなきゃね
入れるようにしなくちゃあかんです
はい そこはあっても どちらの人でもお釈迦様おっしゃってる
自分を観察しなさいという方法で
誰だって正しい道に入ってくるんです
あの 実践してない場合は
人間っていうのはその 2つのカテゴリーに分けられます
ついでに思い出しましたけど
このあのインターネットで
YOUTUBE でね 説法を聞いてると
このオーストラリアのあのお寺から出しているサイトがありましてね
そこであるお坊さんが
オーストラリア人のね
説法するとき出した例なんですけど
自分が知ってるある人がこの末期で
あの そういう末期の人々がいるところがありますね
ホスピス で ホスピス病棟に入ってるんだと
だからすごい もうがんがものすごくもう発生
もう進化してね で そう言ってると
あと命はもう 1ヶ月間
3ヶ月間ともわからないっていう状態になったところで
この人は突然変なことを考えたみたいですね
私は別に何も心配することはないでしょうと
だって 3ヶ月間だからね
で これ食ってはあきませんとかね
お医者さんに言われたんだから
これやってはいけませんとかね
こんなのはどうでもいいやと
やりたい放題やってやるぞと思って
この人はもうグリースの塊の
あの英語では脂肪はケースという場合はグリースというんですね
グリース塊のハンバーガーやいろんなものを食べたり
もう好きなものはケーキやら何でも食べて遊んで楽しく生活することに決めちゃったと
がんが治りましたと 結局は
で ホスピスのところから家に帰っちゃったと
だからこのそれで お坊さんが言ったんだから
本当かどうかもちろんわかりません
私 人のお話をね 引用しただけなんですけど
その人というのは この心の安らぎ
喜びがあれば大丈夫やということですね
そういうことで この普通は人間っていうのはね
2つに分けちゃって ああ大変だとか虚しいと思うのは
長生きすることに価値があると思っているからでしょ
ありえない話でしょうに
初めからもう何やったって虚しいでしょうに
結局はすべて何やっても意味がないでしょうに
考えてみれば ただ そんなことを気にしないで
やるべきことはやる 例えば
人がもうもう本当に危篤状態でいるとしましょう
それでも点滴ででも栄養を与えるんですよ
別に虚しい させましょうとかしないでしょうに
それって一つの妄想の結果やと思います
すごい会社に忠潤で真面目に
もらう給料よりも仕事をしても
会社からがすぐ一つ失敗してただけで追い出す
怒る  10年も真面目に仕事をしても
一個の失敗で だから虚しいや
こんなことはと思う どうでも結局は虚しいんです
年取ったらどうしたっても追い出しますからね
だから自慢げにうちの会社とかね
これまでやったとかね
後で退職してからそんなこと言ったって
みんなに嫌われちゃって
あのじじいが自慢ばっかりで気持ち悪いやと
結局は真面目に頑張っても自慢するチャンスもなくなっちゃうんですね
だから初めから虚しいよって
この人生は ただ五分だけといったところで現れたものじゃないんです
だからこそ 我々は気楽で淡々とやるべきことをやるんです
あまりバカでかい期待しないんです
会社にレポートを書く場合は
バカでかい期待したところで
会社でみんなレポートを見てなんだこりゃと追い出しちゃうとガクーンと落ち込むでしょうに
まあ一応真面目に書きますけどと
だからって これが会社が万々歳で受けるか認めるか
クタクタ非難されるかどうわかりませんだからね
こんなのはどうでもいいと
褒めたっても 私に対してはどうったことはない
自分のプロジェクトは認めたったら会社のプロジェクトになるんだから
どうったことないんです
非難したっても知ったことありませんと
そういう感じで気楽に生きていられると思いますよ
五分命といったら空しいや
もうもうどうしようもないと思うのは
我は永遠なりという無知に陥っている幻覚に陥っているグループなんですね
それ自己観察する人は
最初はそんな幻覚はあっても
自己観察すると心がどんどん変わって
この瞬間の命やという世界に
智慧の世界に成長はします
はい 以上です  さあ あの
あと一人ぐらいどなたかいらっしゃいますか？では
一番前の女性の方  あの先ほどから永遠の世界とかなんか出てるんですけども
キリスト教でも永遠の世界って言ってるし
ヒンズー教でもアウトマンとかトラウマとか
なんか永遠の世界ってよく言葉を聞くんですけど
仏教では今瞬間の世界って聞いたんですけれども
その瞬間の世界っていうのをもう少しわかりやすく
ちょっと私よくわからないので
それちょっとその他の世界のものとの違いっていうか
そこの辺をちょっと教えていただけないかなと思いまして
まあ私はあまりも音が響いちゃって
何言ってるかやっぱりわからなかったんですけど
他の宗教で言っている永遠永遠の世界というものと
仏教で言っている瞬間の世界というものの違いをちょっとわかりにくかったので
わかるようにもう少し説明
だから永遠にあるっていうのは
キリスト 他の宗教も人間みんなそうなんですよ
ある特定の宗教ではないんです
宗教ならみんな永遠に永遠に何かなるかやるか思ってる
あれはね 自分が死ぬっていうことを頭が知ってるんですよ
だからないものねだりなんですね
では 川が永遠でしたと
なんで川があるんですか？永遠じゃないんだから
川でしょ 水が流れるわ
流れるわ 流れるわ 流れるわ流れるわ
だから川というんです
1時間だけ流れて終わったものには川と言いません
時々大雨で道路にも水が流れるでしょ
その時 あ これ川ですと誰も言いません
時々川のようですとは言うんですね
川とは言いません だから川というのは無常だから
瞬間変化するんだから川です
でないと成り立たない
そこで私がしゃべるために
このマイクロフォンの中の電子たちがずっと動いちゃって
自分から持っている物質を外へ出すんです
それで私の口から出てくるエネルギーが入っちゃうと
中の電子たちのもうたまらなくなっちゃって
こちらから入るんだから
それに合わせた何か電子を外へ出すんです
だから私はしゃべるためにマイクロフォンが変わっていくんです
で そこは行って行って
スピーカー あのアンプリファイアを通してスピーカーまで行っちゃうと
皆様には私の声ではなくて別な声を聞いて聞こえているんです
だから今も瞬間瞬間の流れが成り立っているんです
そこで このスピーカーから出てくる音が皆様の耳に入ると
耳の分子たちが新しい物質分子が入るんだから
まあやいやい だから自分持っているものを出すんです
外へ 変化するんです 出したらそこからどんどん脳に行って
脳も変化しちゃって もう幻覚作っちゃって
あれこれやると ずっと無常の流れがキリがなく起きているんです
もし変化しないものを何かあったら
何一つも成り立たないんです
このマイクロフォンは変化しないんだったら
私の声を受け取らないんです
だからマイクロフォンにしたっても
何年間使えるかということは決まってるんです
ということは 何年間が何年間間お前に変化できるのかと
この声に行儀よく変化することに何年耐えられるのかいということで
マイクロフォンの寿命なんです
スピーカーの場合も あなたは何年間この入ってくる電気に合わせて振動を起こせるのかと
だってこちらも紙とかいろんなものできているんだからね
振動を起こして起こして
やがてできなくなっちゃうんです
そこでスピーカーの寿命なんです
そういう風にすべては無常だから成り立ってるんです
ここはもうすごくいきなり理解できないかもしれませんよ
私には永遠の魂があるということは錯覚だから理解しやすいんですね
だって子供たちは怪獣をよく理解しているでしょ
怪獣はなになに怪獣 なになに怪獣
なになにスーパーマン
なんとかウルトラマンとかね
あれは嘘だから簡単に覚えちゃうんですね
で 本当のことはちょっと難しくなります
いろんなスーパーマンやらいろんな怪獣たちやらね
の名前を覚えている子供がね
パワーもカードゲームやってるでしょ
なになに怪獣はこれぐらいパワーを持っていて
これはこんなものに変身するんだよとかね
そこまで覚えているこの子供たちには
2 かける 8 と言ったら
もうこうなっちゃうんですね
そこで指が足らなくなっちゃうんですね
だって16だから10本しかないんだから
指は だからもう本当に
だからちょっと難しくはなります
無常という世界はね でもそれは事実ですよ
例えばバイオリンを見てください
バイオリンがなぜ美しい音を出すんですかね
あれ 棒が触れるたびに新しい新しい振動が生まれるんです
そこに無常の流れが 川のような流れが成り立っているんです
音という何もないんです
この私はその空気の振動を受け取っているんです
もしバイオリンの弦を一つだけニャーと弾いちゃうとどうなるんですかね
気持ち悪くても もうすごい相手を殺したくなるんです
で それでバイオリニストは指を動かしながら上上下動っていきながら
指をこうやって触れながら
こちらでも力の強弱をしながら無常の摂理を作るんですよ
それで音楽なんです ピアノの鍵盤で 1個だけ弾いちゃうと気持ち悪いでしょうに
しかし 勢いで10本の指があの40何個の鍵盤の間で
行ったり来たり 行ったり来たりすると美しい音楽なんです
子供はなんで可愛い？日々変わるんだからなんです
なんで年寄りはそれほど可愛くないんですかね
あまり変化見えないんだからね
だから桜の花 桜が映えちゃうと感動する
そちらにある石はほとんど無視されるんです
あまり変わりはないんだからね
誰も桜の葉っぱ見て葉っぱ見に買いはしませんね
桜の葉を見る 見る会は
何ですね これは 桜の葉は長くいるんだからなんです
桜だけは まあ寒くて長くもちっても 1週間ですね
だから無常だから感動しますよ
逆に永遠な命があったら
それ最悪やと思いますよ
何やっても知らないと言ったらね
最悪ですよ あれは無いものねだりの精神から出てくる気持ちだと思います
時間的にはそれ以上は説明できないが
本当はもしかするとまだまだ理解できないと思ってるかも
私もあまり自信がないので説明したという
無常は仏教と科学が語っているんです
それ以外のみんな このすべてあるんだというスタンスでいるので
あれは特定の宗教の話でもないんです
無神論者たちも結構いるんですからね
そういうことで はい それ以上はちょっと説明難しいと思います
はい そういうことで 最後の
ん？はい 皆様でこの最後の慈しみの言葉を唱えて終了したいと思います
はい 準備してください
ドッカッパッタージェニンンッカ
バヤッパッタージェニンンバヤ
ソーカッパッタージェニスソーカー
ホントゥサンベーピーパーニノ
苦しむものの苦しみがなくなりますように
怯えるものの怯えが消えますように
悲しむものの悲しみがなくなりますように
一切の生命が覚悟のごとくありますように
ありがとうございます
マイク